non mais je suis sûr que sophie chez ton
ski à bah oui oui exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est aussi le hobbit est hostile c'est
vrai qu'est-ce que tu auras lui dire ce
soir
eh bien oui j'aimerais on aimerait
animer avec toi une émission est ce que
ta nouvelle vie va produire conclu dit
il faut que je traduis ci dit oui qu'est
ce qu'il a dit en français quand même
oui mais tu as dit que je voulais animer
une émission avec sophie davant oui
alors je ne suis plus producteur
j'étais chaud mais là tu m'as des
chauffeurs se régler qu'est ce que tu
sais ton style sophie oui c'est vrai
pourquoi
qu'est ce qui te plaît chez elle pas
elle est classe et classe mais elle
doute beaucoup d'elle un doute beaucoup
des de sofiouest en fait extraordinaire
ça me plaît sophie quoi vous août et
beaucoup de vous oui mais oui moi mais
ce jour dans le disent ouais bien sûr
mais aussi de quoi vous pas vos chiens
et des imbéciles qui doutent pas voyez
ce qui est dit c'est fou si doute ici
mais c'est ce que les gens alors et le
mouvement du dock mais oui sophy il veut
nous brancher ensemble sur plus pour
être passe-t-il donc oui j'aimais les
poètes joker alors il est très
intelligent
oui mais moi je ne dis rien et si c'est
vrai c'est découvert après sophie davant
est allé chez le doc je veux rien quoi
sert donc vous dis plus rien non j'ai
raison moi aussi j'ai décidé vraiment de
ne plus rien dire